a new year means some new goals and
maybe getting fit in 2023. yeah maybe
you want to shed some pounds maybe you
just want to get a little bit healthier
fitness experts say the first step is
that step in the door you've got to get
started Candace Charles joining us live
from uh a fitness center let's see I
thought we were going to see her here at
uh Deer Springs there she is Candace is
ready to work out the big question is
are you at home good morning Candice
good morning YouTube good morning folks
that is absolutely a great question
Heather you guys get on up join us right
now the first step really is getting
started the second one is being
realistic now you can do some of these
at home I have Erica here with me from
EOS Fitness thank you so much for
joining us tell us really about how
people can get some of their workouts
their New Year's resolutions started at
home absolutely so anything like this
you can buy at home so we have a band
here you can get this at home you can
tie it to your door you can tie it to
anything and it actually works stability
work arms with it what we're going to
show you today is a little stability
little core little chest I like it we're
gonna have Denise demonstrated for you
and it's pretty simple all right Denise
okay walk me through this she is a
training here she's going to show me how
to do a little bit of Core workout all
right what you're gonna do is step out a
little bit so you've got some resistance
to the band okay I need you to engage
yeah I need you to bend them that's this
part y'all yes I need you to bend your
knees slightly okay think about hugging
a big tree come across your chest okay I
think I got this like this right keep
looking straight okay you got it yes you
get it this is something that you guys
can do at home while you're watching me
on TV like you're doing all right now
seems simple enough this is just one of
the main things you guys can do at home
and really it also is about eating
properly you know what I've been told
you don't have to do too much right to
eat properly right correct you don't
have to do too much just take away that
one out that one uh to go meal that
you're buying every week all right seems
simple enough thank you both I
appreciate it you can save that little
money from that to go mail and come on
down they hear EOS training is available
as well for 30 to 70 dollars but if you
want to come out here and train by
yourself it's only 9.99 to join they
have locations throughout the valley
that you can go to they have uh places
for your child to go so really there are
no excuses guys and I have all the
details for you on their website as
ynewsnow.com coming up we're going to be
doing a little bit more exercising some
of these you also do at home but for now
live from EOS off of Rome I'm Candace
Charles 8 News Now